let's talk about the media's treatment
of you so the media's treatment of you
for
a long time really since you sort of a
rose to international prominence
has been this this mode of attack
whether it is the bbc suggesting that
you're a vicious sexist or the new york
times suggesting that you want to force
women into marriage
or whether now it is ta-nehisi coates
writing comics that portray you as red
skull captain america's
rival the the nazi the he's a nazi
character
what do you make of magic super villain
nazi because nazi
when nazi isn't enough when comparing
you to hitler isn't enough
there's always red skull i think it's
kind of hit a limit because the next
step is satan
[Music]
right i mean that's where you go after
red skull and
uh what do i make of it
oh thank you for your defense by the way
much appreciated oh yeah of course i i
should say look
there have been people in the media
who've been
supportive of me from the beginning i
would say
in canada for example there's four or
five people who
i think are among canada's top
journalists
who have been firm defenders of me
right from the beginning and so it isn't
every single
person in the mainstream media although
there's a disproportionate number of
people in the mainstream media
who go after me compared i think to
my popularity versus unpopularity in the
general public
and i i've thought about it a lot
i'm not exactly sure what to make of it
um i certainly wasn't sure what to make
of the last
red skull episode it was absolutely
shocking to me it took me
about 12 hours to recover because i
couldn't believe it was
actually real to begin with it was so
surreal i i found out about it on
twitter somebody just sent me the
cartoon and
the first thing i thought was that it
was a photoshop uh
mock-up you know just another meme and
then i looked into it a bit and then i
was really
confused that this had occurred it just
seemed especially when i found out who
the author was you know
uh so that was a double shock and
and then i i decided to because i'm i'm
feeling better
and i have my sense of humor back at
least to some degree and so
i decided i just play with it instead of
any of the other possible options that
were open to me and
that's worked out extremely well we've
raised about a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars for charity because of
but it isn't disappearing it doesn't
seem to disappear
and every so often somebody comes out of
the woodwork
and takes another swipe at me and hoping
that
perhaps i don't know hoping i don't know
what hoping that this will be the time
that i finally
get wiped out and you know that's
happened
three or four times in major media
outlets this year alone
uh uh the woman who interviewed me for
gq
um she wrote a couple articles
one in the atlantic monthly helen lewis
and she still seems to be
quite disappointed in the fact that i
exist and decade can head in the lun
in the times in in in the uk she was
quite the piece of work and then
this last episode with tennessee coates
i i thought about i'll tell you what i
think you tell me what you think about
this
you know there are people like me uh in
some ways like stephen pinker jonathan
height
who are public intellectuals who are
standing up against
critical race theory and the worst of
the leftist
propaganda there are
rationalists and atheists in the main
scientists
and i have one foot in that camp but i
also have
a foot in the mythological dramatic
religious camp and you know nellie
bowles who's one of the journalists who
came after me
she's the one who wrote the mia culpa
three or four months ago pointing out
that she used her position
to destroy people's reputation just so
she could attract attention to herself
surprise surprise and you know she
called me defender of the patriarchy
which was a
ironic in some sense her use of that but
also an insult at least from her
perspective but
that's me both sides of it the
rationalist side the enlightenment side
and the religious side
and so have at her boys
that's what i think so i can't think of
any other explanation really
no i think i think that's right i mean
when when i saw what what
coats had done in the captain america
comics and i actually think that it does
go to something root about our
civilization at this point because
you talk a lot jordan obviously about
mythology and the power of myth
and the most american form of myth at
this point in time are the comic books
right i mean graphic novels are the form
of american myth particularly
the marvel universe which is the single
biggest cinematic universe in movie
history at this point
right and and to take captain america
who's the iconic american figure turn
him on his head
so that he's opposing some of the stuff
that you are saying and what you are
saying is reflective of nazi propaganda
it what what it really does is it does
place you in the position of satan
except that the same people
who very often are celebrating satan in
in sort of his juxtaposition to god i
would never treat satan that way i think
that you're worse than satan because
satan
is featured in little mass x videos as
sort of something that ought to be
imitated right there's a celebration of
his rebellious spirit
yeah you're you're foot in that
religious inspirational world you does
differentiate you from a lot of the
other people
who the left has is somewhat targeted
but has decided is not really worthwhile
that's why i think that the way that you
were described in that comic book for
people who missed it
basically the implication was that red
skull was driving people to join
hydra by by issuing his ten rules for
order
and talking about the greatness of
civilization uh and how you should make
your room
and and all of this stuff is is driving
many on the left
up a wall specifically because it's
inspirational the left knows that when
it comes to driving the human heart
it's not enough to be a rationalist you
actually have to offer an inspirational
program and i think this is the great
irony is that folks like coates
they do offer an inspirational program
but their inspirational program
is an inspiration to tear down exactly
the institutions of western civilization
you defend which is why he has created
this dichotomy
yeah well it's something that everyone
needs to take seriously across the
political spectrum i mean it's quite
clear that we need
a story along with our politics
and that's because the human heart
demands an adventure
and that's especially true if you're
young you know the
the developmental psychologist john
piaget who's
who's a genius a recognized genius
he has a stage of development he posited
the last stage of development as in
adolescence as the messianic stage
it isn't talked about much in
developmental psychology literature i
mean
piaget was actually trying to reconcile
religion and science that was his life's
work and he
investigated the development of ethics
empirically
in an attempt to bridge the gap between
the is and
isn't ought and um and he was very very
serious about that
it drove his whole enterprise in any
case he pointed out that
there is a stage of development in late
adolescence that he called the messianic
stage where people are
looking for i suppose they're catalyzing
their identity at the broadest possible
level which
which we would describe as religious i
don't care if you're religious or not
that's irrelevant to this discussion
at the point at the highest level of
generality
your identity the best language to
describe your identity happens to be
religious which is why we have a
religious language speaking purely from
a psychological perspective and
what that means is that there has to be
a call to adventure
in order to keep people motivated
to move forward in their life both as
individuals and as
members of society and look george
orwell really knew
this about the fascists for example i
mean orwell was a
profound anti-fascist i mean profound in
the emotional sense and also in the
analytic sense and but he recognized
very early
and and had the courage also to point
out
that the nazis had conjured up
a mythos that was unbelievably powerful
and that
the rationalist west had nothing in its
armament to contend with that
and fascism in some sense is it's it's
more difficult to mount a rational
defense against than communism
because the fascists do use non-verbal
appeal
and and hitler used fire and imagery and
fashion and
architecture and art and and culture in
the broadest sense
to move his political platform forward
the leftists in especially in the us
are quite good at the dramatic end of
politics
you know and and the the antifa riots
that sort of thing the black life
matters black lives matter protests
they're appealing to young people and
you can imagine
i always remember i saw this kid in
montreal once he's about 17 and
he's dressed in punk clothes he's a big
kid six foot five like a big powerful
kid
and he was standing on the corner of
this outdoor shopping mall with two pink
shopping bags
in his hand and he looked like a fool
and it was partly because he felt like a
fool because there he was this like
monster
standing there with these pink shopping
bags and i looked at him and i thought
geez you know if you went and offered
him an overseas adventure
a warlike overseas adventure he'd drop
those damn bags and he'd be gone in a
second
and no wonder and so it's
incumbent on us to realize that that
call to adventure is necessary and
that it has to be built in in some
manner into our political
uh our political thinking and the left
is very very good at that
they're much better the radical left
they're much better than the left
centrists
and they're much better than the
centrist right now trump managed that to
some degree with his populism
but not to the same degree as the
intellectuals the dramatic intellectuals
on the left
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show sunday special if you
did
go ahead and hit the subscribe button so
you stay up to date on all of our future
content